In this lesson, we're going to take a look at GPU lightmass and take an overview on how
it works.
So let's get started.
So the first thing we're going to ask, you're probably going to ask is what exactly is this?
Well this is using a light baking system, but we're going to be leaning on our GPU to
be able to build.
We're not going to be using the CPU based lightmass system, so it improves upon that.
It leverages DirectX 12 DXR ray tracing capabilities to speed things up.
It significantly reduces the time it takes to build a complex scene.
It achieves speeds on a single host comparable to distributed swarm render, which we saw
that earlier where you can actually use a swarm agent.
It makes it so that we're leaning on the GPU versus the CPU to be able to do so.
So it's using a progressive lightmapper with optional real-time preview in the viewport.
So you can actually see it going on.
You want to make sure your virtual texturing is on if you want to be able to see this display
correctly.
Offering multiple modes for building lighting, full bake and bake what you see, significantly
increases the speed of lightbakes for complex scenes, producing a more physically accurate
result than CPU based lightmass.
Let's go ahead and take a look at this up close and we're going to convert a lumen scene
into a GPU lightmass bake scene and I'll show you some of the ins and outs and things you
have to look out for.
So let's go and jump into Unreal.
In my Unreal scene, I'm going to go ahead and open up my project settings.
In here, we want to make sure we turn on allow static lighting.
We turned that off before, but we're going to turn that on now.
We want to go into rendering and then convert everything to a non-lumen scenario.
What does that mean?
Well, I'm changing my dynamic global illumination method to screen space.
That way when we bake, we might, we should be able to actually get some, a little bit
of glow for those lamps in our scene and kind of capture some of that lumen realism.
Still going to be at a disadvantage as you can already see the preview shadows here are
kind of blobby, but once we do a bake on full production, we'll get pretty close, although
we will not get the real time update we would get with lumen as we move the light around
because our light has changed mobility too.
It needs to be changed to stationary versus movable.
So once we set all this reflection method to screen space, as well as our shadow method
to shadow maps, we also want to make sure in our post-process volume, once we've got
all this down, and again, you want to be under rendering, changing it from lumen to a screen
space, you want to go to our post-process volume and do the same.
Change the global illumination method to screen space and change the reflection method to
screen space.
We're going to go ahead and restart.
So once you've rebooted and you've also turned on allow static lighting and you also have
ray tracing active, again, I do recommend, and I'm going to emphasize this, is you turn
on virtual texturing for some support for your view port modes.
Now it may not be as dependent as it used to be to be able to have that on, but you
will see some progress bars hopefully showing up in your scene to be able to see things
as they go.
Now it's really not necessary.
It's just a fancy thing to be there, but you can also turn those off if you don't want
those at any time.
You can turn them off if you don't need them.
I don't really care if they're on because I get the percentages at the bottom.
It tells me how it's going and there's our build lighting.
So let me walk you through some of these settings.
Now you'll notice immediately there's quite a difference between this and Lumen.
We'll also notice though that the materials are handled a bit better though with baking,
but we are getting that banding from screen space reflections.
So there is a difference between a give or take between both of these.
You also notice that there are some little bit of light leaking going on.
So we have to again make sure that our lightmap resolution is to the level that we want for
each item and also make sure that the floor is not paper thin.
Now if it's paper thin and not thick, you can see it is paper thin.
That can be an issue sometimes where you will get some bleeding of shadows and light.
So we would probably have to go back and rebuild this floor and make it thick like it actually
is in the real world.
These are things a lot of people don't consider when working and baking items.
And it's also a good idea to have thick and actual geometry you can punch into when it
comes to Lumen too.
So overall it's just a very good practice to have.
You'll see in the mode here we have a full bake or bake what you see.
This is beneficial.
If you don't want to go through the whole system there, you can actually do partial.
You can press your lightmap so we can actually turn this off and run this again.
Right now that's one of the reasons we are getting a little bit of a blobby shadow or
not as accurate as we had for Lumen.
You can also have denoise on completion and you can turn that on or off if you want to.
And the denoise are overall.
There's a global illumination samples and says 512.
I always start at the default and then as I need I can increase things and you'll see
there's a stationary shadow samples here, light shadow samples and you can increase
that.
Which is usually pretty decent, but again on a more macro level you can actually go
to each one of these pieces of geometry and increase those light maps as you need them.
So those keep those things in mind.
And there's also use iridescent here.
Make sure I say it correctly.
This is catching should be enabled with interior scenes to achieve more physically accurate
GI intensities.
So just keep those in mind.
Now we're using screen space, but we all still getting a glowing material and that's
a nice thing about working with screen space.
You can give off a little bit of light.
You'll see a little bit here, but you also see a change when I move my camera.
So again, another reminder about the limitations with screen space.
OK, so let's look at a few more things here.
You'll see a quality multiplier so we can increase that if we need to for volumetric
light map that helps with our moving characters with our volumetric environment detail cell
size we can.
So it's basically kind of a dumbed down.
Think of it as a dumbed down version of our regular CPU light mass in our world settings.
This is a kind of a dumbed down, easier to get to type of interface kind of gives you
the meat of your control versus all the little ins and outs you actually can go straight
to and then it'll favor the GPU.
Now, GPU does not support certain things such as a light mass portal.
So if we created a light mass portal and put it here in front of the window so we have
a difference between the light area of the outside and the darker area in the interior,
it will not support that.
So CPU light baking supports that more than this does.
OK, so there's just a few more items here you can mess with.
You can do aggressive leak prevention.
We could turn that on to prevent any leaking going on.
Now remember your light maps and the thickness of geometry.
Those can also play a factor for some issues that may occur.
So there's also you'll notice a first bounce ray guiding all these things as we turn them
on and we adjust them and say hey I want to be able to play with these settings.
You'll notice this particular one is grayed out.
So I wouldn't worry about this one too much but it does do the number of samples used
for first bounce ray guiding which are thrown away before sample lighting.
I don't normally mess with this one.
So I think you're OK keeping that gray.
You don't necessarily have to turn that or activate that one on.
You'll see there's a real time workload factor.
Again this tries to help with your workload for your heavy scenes.
There's a non real time workload factor.
This is baking speed multiplied with real time.
When real time is disabled in the viewer.
So if you turn that off in your viewer you actually can have that.
So it's kind of speeds things up a little bit.
And then you also have your light map tile pool size.
The default should work fine but feel free to bump that up.
And again this gives you GPU light mass manages your pool size for calculations and invisible
tiles.
So it really tries to help you with that.
Now my first pick is aluminum.
That's my first pick.
But I wanted to walk you through these because there will be scenarios where you may have
to do this particularly with virtual production particularly like say you're working in ICV
effects and just your machines just don't like lumen or your materials very particular
and lumen gives you too much noise.
You could go this route but be very deterministic.
Test it out ahead of time.
See what you're going to get ahead of time.
If you don't you won't know.
So you don't want to be stuck on stage.
You don't be stuck in front of your art director and you don't know your options.
So this again this class is really mainly to help you with that and decide what you
need based on what you have.
I do want to mention a cute a couple more points that you have here underneath lighting.
You'll notice you can also use error coloring.
This will color areas which are you're getting like some errors in your computation.
It'll color those areas for you so you can find it in your light map.
Also there's show lighting stats.
You can actually get that in here and this will tell you what's going on.
It'll tell you your metrics and stuff and tell you how your performance is doing.
All right awesome sauce.
So again let's reiterate some of the things that you cannot do.
So lightmass portals are not supported.
Pixel depth offset is not supported.
Lighting channels are not supported.
So keep that in mind.
Use lightmass importance volumes to help with volumetric light maps which you heard me talk
about before.
It uses as a focal area for your moving items.
It's very crucial in this case with GPU lightmass.
Also you will logically need that for your terrain if you have terrain.
Texture encoding and denoising a run on the CPU and are not affected by the multi GPU.
But you did see some of those options for it because they're still talking to each other
but mainly you're leaning on your GPU for speed.
We have stationary skylight currently not supported but on the roadmap.
And then we have custom settings and properties of lights.
So what that means is when you have maybe you've injected a custom light in there and
maybe you're even editing some of those deep dive test it out first I recommend.
So like if I'm working with direct lighting let me show you real quick here.
You'll notice in Unreal we do have a section.
Oh I zoomed down my camera next and I meant to wheel scroll over here.
You'll notice lightmass this is no longer.
Now this is CPU based mostly but you can help out with a few things.
So your light source will still work light source angle your indirect lighting saturation
test that out to make sure it's giving you what you want.
Shadow exponent.
These were originally created with CPU light baking in mind.
But you always for good measure you always want to make sure that your stationary light
that your excuse me your area shadows for stationary light that is on that's going to
give you a better shadow quality.
And when you do this you'll have to do a remake.
You can also do such things as light shafts.
But again test things out as you go because there are some of these customizations which
may not work a one to one to what you have with the CPU bake.
And there's lots of customization in CPU versus GPU.
So if you are very specific on a particular look and feel and a tool test it out first
and do a comparable because such things as like we said the light mass that we saw here.
That's actually we can get this out of the way.
We saw that the light mass portals.
These little guys aren't supported.
So there are a few things that are very particular for CPU baking and also pixel depth offset
is not supported.
So just keep those things in mind.
Here's a link for additional information on these topics.
Feel free to dive in and take a look.
In the next video we're going to do an interactive session here where I will be lighting a character.
He's a bit more stylized not really a metahuman but we're going to have some fun with him
and you feel free to follow along as I go through that workflow.
That's it.